[Musique]
madeleine blé mort un bon soir stéphanie
chouinard politicologue je le rappelle
au collège militaire royal du canada
toronto bonsoir stéphanie est vrai qu
boily que l'on retrouve politologue à
l'université de l'alberta edmonton
bonsoir à vous trois on sort on a vu ces
images on va les revoir toutes ces
images aujourd'hui le plus de jours
tout va dépendre de demain madeleine
d'envoi pas si il bloque lui-même fait
c'est tout à fait dans le cadre d'une
démocratie d'exprimer sa colère même si
on n'est pas d'accord
oui évidemment ça peut causer un petit
peu d'ennui à la population d'ottawa on
sent dans le centre ville d'ottawa va
devenir impraticable en raison de ces
centaines de camions qui devrait
converger vers le centre ville mais d'un
point de vue de sécurité évidemment il
peut y avoir une manifestation est
pacifique comme ça peut dégénérer et
c'est pour ça que des policiers sont
très prudent de se montrer tout près de
ce mouvement là sachant pas de quel côté
ça peut virer donc évidemment et renou
tulsi savais que tout serait pacifique
qu'ils représenteraient des camionneurs
il n'hésiterait pas à se rendre sur la
colline du parlement mais c'est pas
certain que c'est comme ça que ça va se
dérouler et c'est pas pour rien car un
o'toole a décidé de rencontrer des
camionneurs à l'extérieur du périmètre
de la colline du parlement justement
pour pas être associé à un mouvement qui
pourrait dégénérer il veut pas de photo
avec plein de drapeaux liberté c'est
fanny chouinard dans quel dans quel
mouvement ça s'inscrit dans un mouvement
de colère bien sûr on a vu ils se sont
financées quand même assez bien 6
millions le sur les les réseaux etc
comment vous le placez sur mouvement là
mais c'est un mouvement je pense qu'il
ya un peut attraper plusieurs éléments
de grande vis-à-vis du gouvernement bon
évidemment on sait qu'une partie de ces
camionneurs qui contestent la
vaccination obligatoire
bien que bon si gouvernement canadien
décidé de faire volte-face sur cette
position là il rencontrerait le même
problème du côté américain mais il ya
d'autres enjeu qui se sont un peu
attaché à ce phénomène le bon on a
entendu des camionneurs qui ne sont pas
nécessairement compte la vaccination
mais qui disent que leurs conditions de
travail depuis le début de la pandémie
ont été très difficiles on sait que
parmi les organisateurs il ya des
éléments disons un peu plus extrémistes
aussi notamment bon là les organisateurs
qui fait partie des soldats dodine donc
c'est ça fait partie de la raison je
pense pour laquelle les politiciens se
sont entendus sur leurs gardes drake
boily donc c'est ça
c'est organisé dans
certains sous groupes de cette
manifestation par des groupes vraiment
d'extrême droite le faut le dire c'est
clair domi ramasse aussi un ras-le-bol
qui plus large le cercle s'agrandit y
effectivement que ça grandit parce que
on peut effectivement trouver une
origine dans certains groupes et
d'ailleurs lorsque le financement comme
en c1
c'est un groupe où des gens associés au
parti ou excite tous qui était associé
au parti ou excite maintenant le parti
amérique donc je pense qu'il ya une
origine grison de l'eau ouest canadien
il faut se souvenir aussi qu'il ya déjà
eu un autre convoi en février 2019 qui
était partie également de la liberté qui
était descendue vers ottawa - un
important
savait créer 10 ont moins de débord mais
en même temps ça montre que c'est pas un
phénomène qui est totalement inédit
l'eau ce qui est inédit c'est que ça
semble fédérer ou si d'autres groupes de
l'extérieur de l'ouest canadien c'est à
dire que on voit des manifestement du
côté du québec du côté des maritimes
aussi convergé vers ottawa mais ça
s'inscrit évidemment sur la grande toile
de fond des mesures sanitaires et de
cette contestation des mesures
sanitaires qui varie d'un individu à
l'autre dans toute cette grande mouvance
et c'est intéressant ce que vous n'êtes
pas ce que ça origines de loin ça c'est
clair nous et on l'a déjà vu mais là
c'est différent c'est que ça fait des
d'autres personnes en colère et là il ya
toutes sortes de la liste est longue de
toutes les mesures sanitaires il passe
en fait madeleine on va entendre
monsieur o'toole et monsieur trudeau il
ya deux jours deux positions très
différentes
face à ce mouvement
chaque canadien chaque québécois
méritent un voir ici à aux droits
incluront les camionneurs et il y a des
autres que qui va utiliser le camp nou
et pour leurs intérêts problème pour les
manifestations mais c'est injuste aussi
on doit respecter
la manifestants on paie mais c'est
pourquoi les conservateurs vont être là
pour tous les canadiens mais j'aimerais
voir un dix escales à sion à des
détentions et canadiens se préoccupent
de leur liberté de leurs droits oui ils
savent que la meilleure façon de
protéger leurs droits et de leur liberté
c'est d'en finir avec cette pandémie les
propos que tiennent certains des gens
associés à ce qu'on veut qu'on voit sont
inacceptables et sont inacceptables pour
la vaste majorité des canadiens
donc madeleine on le voit politiquement
monsieur trudeau a pas beaucoup de
dangers n'y a pas de risque beaucoup de
tourner le dos à ces gens lapidaire
attention le moi je m'associe 0 al
vous avez raison mais en même temps
justin trudeau au politiser cette
question de la vaccination obligatoire
lieu commencé en campagne électorale il
y en a fait un enjeu
polarisant exprès pour essayer de piéger
ernaux toul et encore hier
justin trudeau lorsqu'il a commencé sa
réunion du caucus virtuel il ya dix mois
je me tenir debout devant des
politiciens quand on comme et renault
tool qui pensent qu'on peut en faire
moins pour ce qui est de la vaccination
donc voyez vous c'est comme si il est
toujours attiré vers cette idée de
politiser ce d'ebola parce qu'ils
pensent que c'est paya visiblement et
renault tools en piètre tout le temps
dans cette question là donc c'est
difficile quand même d'essayer de faire
diminuer la pression essayer d'avoir un
débat qui est un peu plus ce serait
moins - un durcissement finalement des
positions quand on ramène toujours ça à
la question politique et un mot pour
vous dire patrice quand vous dites y'a
pas de risques politiques y en a pas
vraiment à court terme mais en même
temps si la société vraiment diffuser si
le parlement est vraiment diffusé pour
un gouvernement minoritaire ça peut être
plus compliqué de faire adopter des
projets de loi ça peut être un peu plus
compliqué d'avoir des compromis donc
quand même c'est pas vrai que 0-0
risques pour justin trudeau que peut
faire c'est fanny et frédéric le chef
conservateur devant ce parce qu'il ya du
vrai monde devant lui la psa ça fait
aussi partie de sa base même si le parti
conservateur est plus large que les gens
qui manifestent que peut-il faire
comment peut-il se positionner stéphanie
est assez difficile pour une autoroute
et que son caucus était déjà divisé qui
avait déjà de la grogne par rapport à la
façon dont il avait amené là dans la
dernière campagne électorale on sait
aussi que dans certaines
circonscriptions et notamment parmi des
membres forts de son caucus il ya une
peur de l'augmentation d'une part du
vote vers le parti populaire du canada
elle sait pas anodin qu'une candice
bergen par exemple est un film sorti sur
twitter dans les médias publics pour
soutenir les camionneurs elle sait que
ça chauffe dans sa propre
circonscription et qu'elle doit répondre
à cette grogne là qui se manifeste entre
autres par la manifestation des
camionneurs donc si ça ça mais un au
tour dans une position très très
difficile où d'un côté je veux pas avoir
l'air de s'associer avec des éléments
plus nauséabond mais d'un autre côté il
doit répondre aussi aux membres de son
caucus qui entendent dans ce
regroupement la des doléances qui
s'entendent sur le tard et non leur
concert tout ça ils font écho à ce
qu'ils entendent sur le terrain
frédéric un pour qui c'est plus facile
d'embrasser tout ça c'est monsieur
bernier
oui monsieur bernier peut en dresser
soit parce que ça correspond aussi
monsieur bernier préconise une sorte de
dison moi de ce que j'appelle populisme
protestataires et llosa dans le convoi
également c'est à dire une sorte de
protestation d'une partie de la
population contre
l'imposition de mesures sanitaires et
pour monsieur bernie oui on peut surfer
un moment sur ce le problème c'est qu'il
ya de la concurrence aussi à l'intérieur
du parti conservateur comme vienne
mentionné stéphanie certains membres du
parti conservateur pierre poilievre
également qu'ils peuvent maintenant
penser peut-être vouloir jouer également
cette carte du populisme protestataires
et donc faire concurrence à monsieur
bernier sur son propre terrain il ya
certains ténors conservateurs qui
pensent même que le parti conservateur
sourire et un autre devrait tendre la
main à monsieur bernier on a pu lire çà
cette semaine dans nationale pousse donc
dans ce contexte la suite chirurgie des
chirurgies
absolument la grande famille
conservatrice présentement canadienne de
manière générale est sous tensions
idéologiques entre diverses factions du
fait divers ou idéologique et on eu
beaucoup de difficulté à se trouver un
programme comme à l'intérieur même des
formations politiques que ce soit pour
une autre jason kenney même d'autres
chefs conservateur on va attendre
monsieur bernier est suivi de
l'animateur de droite aux états unis et
sur fox stocker carlson qui a fait
naître avec un des camionneurs impliqués
y est active dans la manifestation lui
disait alesi peut aller au bout on est
avec vous on écoute tout ça nous faisons
une bataille pour changer l'opinion
publique et s'assurer que plus de
canadiens qui s'aperçoivent tout comme
nous que ces mesures autoritaires n'ont
aucun effet sur la probable propagation
du virus
m
il a dit attends que vous êtes dans
notre groupe est vraiment une
inspiration vous regarde comme un modèle
et c'est donc
ses seuls sur la carte politique un
danger en même temps madeleine je le
répète pour la troisième fois depuis le
début de l'émission c'est une
manifestation s'il n'y a pas de gros
dérapage c'est normal que dans une
société il ya des gens qui disent on
n'en peut plus puis ça fait deux ans que
ça dure
ça peut exister en démocratie droit de
manifester c'est un droit et j'étais
constamment au canada et on le étant
mieux que ça existe moi je m'attends pas
quand même à ce que ça dure quelques
heures puis après ça que ce soit fini
bonsoir n'ont imaginé patrice il ya des
gens qui arrivent de la colombie
britannique qui ont conduit pendant des
milliers de kilomètres pour venir ici à
ottawa ça me surprendrait qui regardent
le parlement edzoa c'est bien beau en
retourne chez nous j'ai quand même
l'impression que ça va durer quelques
jours le début des travaux
parlementaires la reprise des travaux
c'est lundi moi j'ai bien l'impression
que ça va faire servir de fond de scène
à cette reprise des travaux là et on
voyait dans tout ce débat l'eau c'est en
fait ce sont les conservateurs
ironiquement qui ont essayé de mettre ça
à l'avant-plan parler du sort des
camionneurs ils ont essayé de ramener ça
à un enjeu économique et sont plus forts
sur ce terrain là plus fort ils ont
l'impression qu'ils ont un avantage face
aux libéraux en voulant en faire une
question
d'inflation de difficultés des chaînes
d'approvisionnement et penser qu'ils
avaient un clou sur lequel il pouvait
frapper et ils ont été ramenés sur la
question de la pandémie là où ils sont
plus fragiles donc ils se sont fait
jouer un mauvais tour avec ce dossier là
c'est oui évidemment une question de
tension et des lots idéologique ou
est-ce qu'on dirige deux parties plus à
droite de façon plus dur ou pas mais il
ya aussi cette question pandémie versus
économies se sont fait jouer un mauvais
tour ouais ça révèle le plus enviable où
j'avais freiné ray que ça révèle des
fractures énorme encore dans ce parti là
qui arrive pas à faire là la somme de
ces deux grandes composantes c'est fanny
frais et qu'est-ce que vous surveillez
dans les provinces de main bien sûr mais
dans les prochains jours aux communs
tous comment vous voyez la suite des
choses stéphanie
la première chose ce sera de voir si la
manifestation de mort pacifique c'est ce
qu'on souhaite évidemment comme le
disait madeleine c'est un endroit au
canada de manifester de manifester
pacifiquement on sait que la sécurité
sur la colline parlementaire déjà fait
état au député du fait que leur adresse
personnelle avait circulé sur certains
sites d'extrême droite donc leur avait
recommandé de rester à la maison de
barrez leur porte leur fenêtre et s'est
donc de manifester oui mais des menaces
individuel ça n'a pas de place en
démocratie donc d'une première chose
l'autre chose que je vais surveiller ce
sera de voir si le ton de monsieur
trudeau change dans les prochains jours
ci comme madeleine le dis on voit que
cette manifestation là elle demeure à ta
voix pendant des jours si c'est en effet
le fond de scène sur lequel la
rouverture du parlement se donnera est
ce que monsieur trudeau va tromper
peut-être d'adoucir son discours
vis-à-vis des canadiens et des
canadiennes qui ressemble peut-être un
certain malaise vis-à-vis d'une partie
du discours mais qui rassemble aussi les
doléances de certains des camionneurs
qui ressemble grand jeu de l'économie de
l'inflation qui fait aussi partie de ce
discours là et sur lequel le
gouvernement actuellement était quand
même assez faible oui frédéric
le jury de bénéfices passion parce que
plus ça va durer plus à vos maîtres
justin trudeau dans une position
difficile d'une certaine façon si ça
dure trop longtemps ils vont se
retrouver dans la même position qu
emmanuel macron avec les gilets jaunes à
savoir comment on répond à ce type de
manifestation
seulement balayant du revers de la main
ou en essayant d'apporter quelques
réponses très intéressant merci beaucoup
on va refaire ça très bon trio merci à
vous trois on suit sans fin de semaine
bien sûr au revoir
au revoir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne
hier d